dans cette agence de voyage dans l'une
des spécialités est le territoire
chinois
l'on ne s'attend pas ce que le différend
entre la chine et le canada et surtout
les mises en garde des gouvernements est
un effet dissuasif important je pense
plus fort beaucoup d'impact je pense
plutôt sain moyens diplomatiques pour
faire part au pays mais s'il voit ainsi
qu'un pack mais pas au point d'être
catastrophique mais selon tourisme
montréal la crise sino canadienne qui a
commencé avec la sphère où un oui à la
fin de l'année dernière risque de
freiner la progression du tourisme
chinois qui ne se dément pas depuis
trois ans il est passé de 50 milles à
150 milles en 2018 2019 sera l'année des
incertitudes on pensait atteindre à peu
près deux cent dix mille touristes donc
son père 5 à 7% de ceux à peu près dix à
quinze mille touristes chinois qui me
répond une déception pour tourisme
montréal qui ne lésinent pas lorsqu'il
s'agit de mesures pour recevoir avec
tous les honneurs la clientèle chinoise
particulièrement dans le secteur de
l'hôtellerie cours de mandarin formation
du personnel entre autres afin que cette
crise l'or perdues c'est certain qu'ils
vont au départ on va le turc au point
selon les entrepreneurs d'origine
chinoise sont aussi sur le qui-vive
canada-chine pme est une association qui
aide les gens d'affaires chinois à
s'installer au québec et les
entrepreneurs québécois en chine les
tensions entre le canada et la chine
refroidissent les ardeurs de certains
les gens sont nerveux et demander si on
devrait continuer à la mission avec tout
ce qui est arrivé est ce qu'on va
arrêter certainement certains sont mêlés
fraigne ouattara au pouvoir
on commence à savoir par ac les
dirigeants de l'association qui prévoit
une mission en chine
l'automne prochain conseil aux membres
de maintenir le cap
les affaires des enfants faux pas aura
ont salé affaire très politique je pense
que des relations d'affaires surtout
avec la chaîne
c'est des relations qui s'établissent à
longtemps des relations confiantes
selon ce dirigeant de siemens une
entreprise qui offre un soutien
logistique aux sociétés du secteur du
divertissement tels que le cirque du
soleil qui font d'affaires en chine
cette crise doit inciter les canadiens à
respecter leurs obligations et sur deux
effectué tout ce qui est nouveau
l'immigration au niveau permanent au
niveau licence d'affaires pour éviter
d'avoir des démêlés avec les autorités
chinoises
ici maxime bertrand radio canada n'ont
rien